here's how chess works when you play
chess
you have sit down you have your ideas
and your opponent sits down and they
have their ideas and it's usually easy
to see our own ideas like oh I have
matin three Delta Delta Delta but if you
just ignore your opponent's ideas and
they have Mayton too then you you've
missed everything and the game's over so
today we're going to be looking at the
topic of prophylaxis and we're just
going to do some more puzzles I tend to
like to do these these classes with
puzzles let's go ahead and get this
board ready to go here and Jenny what
prophylaxis is what is it yeah so
prophylaxis right it's preventing your
opponent from doing whatever they're
planning on doing so if you ask yourself
you know what does my opponent want to
do in this position then you can say
okay what can I do to prevent that idea
and that's called prophylaxis we'll get
it on the board so we can sort of see
this is the game between henrik
Danielson and thomas luthor from 1999
and this game continued with a nice
attack for white so white is obviously
on the attack here and in this position
black played Bishop to e7 so we want to
ask ourselves you know what is it that
black wants to play if it's his turn
that's usually a useful thing to ask and
I find that as you progress in chess
eventually it just becomes secondhand
it's like you're always thinking about
me and him you'd always think of both
plans you sort of have like ego respect
you're always your first thing is like
what are they doing but you have to sort
of get in the habit that's not something
that just comes naturally at least not
to most people so here I'll give you
guys a couple minutes here you might
want to pause at home because whenever I
stop talking that all gets cut out and
then they get a lot more time than you
do at home
so if you need more time it's worth
pausing so ask yourself what is it that
black wants to do that's the first thing
before you just start doing random moves
and after you establish what black will
do on his turn only then can we start to
think how can we prevent him from doing
this idea so I'll give you guys just a
minute here all right can West yeah if
it's blacks turn he wants to take on g5
so this this we understand he's
attacking it several times and obviously
due to the pin well you can take back on
the H file but then trading and your
queens on each one okay but you know
he's gonna at least win upon here so we
have to do something about this as white
and so the move played in the game was
was pretty nice in this puzzle you guys
have a chance of solving but don't worry
the ones that the Grandmaster couldn't
solve I'm not going to show you don't
worry those ones those ones were right
out yeah so this this little move Queen
to h5 and that's not a move you would
typically expect but once you start
thinking okay how do I prevent him from
taking on g5 then you start to get these
ideas oh maybe I can make a pin on the H
file and so that was played in the game
and it's actually quite a strong move
and we'll show the game because it
didn't go that much longer and again if
you're thinking what does black want to
do well he probably wants to start
thinking about castling queenside which
means he's got to move his knight he's
got to move his queen and then he can
castle so he moved his knight out of the
way that's step one for him and now
white made a move that you know we could
describe as a prophylactic move you'll
notice all right the bishop can go to c5
and if the bishop has to stay there then
it's in the way of the night so this
move is good and developing your pieces
nothing wrong with that but what's funny
is even though you only have your queen
out there you already can think about
the winning blow with f6 this also is
very strong you can already just go for
it and the computer wants you to sack a
piece on f6 and it says you're down a
piece because if you take then g6 is
pretty annoying so he already could have
had a strong winning attack just
straight out of the opening but
developing your pieces
also quite strong and okay white is
still winning in this position it's just
a matter of being able to prove it here
and after Queen d6 we'll pause one more
time again by now I think hopefully we
we know what black wants to play in this
position black wants to Castle queenside
and this move is a little bit trickier
so I kind of like this this move it's
it's a little bit more complicated so
we're still warming up for the really
tough stuff yeah okay you want to play
here and then after here you're doing
what Bishop to h3 to prevent castling
that's okay that's quite an interesting
idea I assume I mean I could drop my
knight back as lame as it looks
yes f6 is definitely one of the the
moves too to consider here and after I
take yeah you wanted to play Bishop h3
this is actually quite a strong idea I
doubt I can just drop my knight back
because of g6 looks pretty good and I
don't know I guess I have to like take
this or drop my Queen in or or something
like this and yeah this is still
pleasant for white so this also is a
very acceptable answer well it's not the
one played in the game no if you play
that in a game you play f6 and you play
Bishop h3 you're doing great so you have
to imagine in your head if you kind of
had two moves if they castled and you
could play two moves in a row what would
you like to do but don't worry this is
the easy one the next puzzle
so in the game white here play Knight to
a3 that everybody was thinking about but
nobody nobody said and the point is yeah
if they Castle Knight to b5 and the
problem for black is your queen doesn't
have very many squares to go to if you
go here then Knight a seven you can't go
anywhere else so you have to play here
and now rook to d1 Trading lots of stuff
you want to trade all the stuff and then
I mean I can take here right and kick
you away and then I can take care yeah
we don't we don't want to trade all the
stuff here
so I heard yeah I heard part of the idea
yeah excellent
yeah f6 with the Canwest idea of Bishop
to h3 is really strong here much
stronger than just like taking this pawn
or something this is nothing here and if
you like just go back
alright this move is actually quite
strong and suddenly the tables have
turned
notice how you can't take do to Queen d2
and then the game didn't last much
longer so just for for fun let's just
see the conclusion he played c6 now rook
d1 was actually the strongest move here
but he played Knight to c4 which also is
winning and after these trades and
castles again a lot of moves white could
play here but just to see the conclusion
black here just I don't know what he was
thinking so this move just moves is
really really fast I got I don't know
really know what he was thinking so I
mean that just he took this and all the
tactics worked out for white so that was
the conclusion of the game but it was
all based on this first idea the only
way to really find this this winning
plan here is to understand what black is
going to do so when you understand he's
going to take on g5 you might come up
with this rather creative way of
stopping him from going through with
what he wants to do alright so now we
got a another example here we'll flip
the board so the last one was an example
of being on the attack and using
prophylaxis on the attack this one is an
example of using prophylaxis when you're
on the defense and this is the game
between Dimitar donjev and I'm going to
mess up all right vs. Savchenko from
1994 because that's how much I can read
and in this position we'll look at what
happened so in this position it's white
that starts a big attack and after a few
moves here just so we can get a feeling
for the plot so after g4 it's white that
is thinking about an attack he's going
to play g5 he's going to play Queen h5
and I'll give you this this first one
this could be a part of it but I'd
rather get to the
the main plot here here black played the
prophylactic g6 which after if you play
g5 you're not going to bring your queen
in here so that's a very prophylactic
move but we got this position and white
goes here so now I'll let you guys think
about this position so we want to be
thinking about what White's next move is
because if you missed his next move it's
going to be a disaster and after that
we're going to think about what can we
do to prevent that idea from happening
it's too simple it's too easy to stop
okay yeah so as he's indicated yeah he's
going here so that's that's something we
should try to avoid yeah wonder we also
have Shaq the rook and then make Queen
h4 with ko mmm okay so you thinking
about taking and I might take back your
community for our tempo when I went out
on g8 you're gonna find a way to check
Mamie I guess so consideration over
there yeah yeah so yeah Rick Rick h7
also looks pretty pretty deadly here so
yeah don't yeah don't don't don't forget
about that guy so that's gonna be very
very important in a lot of variations we
see
okay so pawn to e5 was suggested and I'm
glad because I was ready for that one I
saw that one coming
this move is actually no good because of
the surprising where it go all right I
didn't go anywhere but okay
the move is is nine to five oh then yeah
this is just going the wrong way
okay there's all sorts of combinations
of like taking and opening up my my
bishop and yeah okay opening the G file
is is going to be pretty good for me
so this actually is very dangerous
I'm so naughty five
the night of six okay so a very
interesting move right and this is the
correct answer and yeah so after you
took here what was the next move you
wanted to play you want to play Knight
f6 okay I assume I should take the
opportunity to toss this just check in
while I can let's just keep the H file
open you can take it that's fine and
then then I get to consider if I get to
take on a7 and bring my queen in and use
my bishop here you know I'm thinking
like I'll check you if you go back I
know I can do something like this looks
looks pretty looks pretty scary you're
half right
which isn't right enough but we're
getting there so that is the problem
right so in this position if you stopped
here too and you said you know what is
white gonna do he needs the position to
be as open as possible so his next move
here is h7 and then deal with lots of
dangerous threats some so King h7
preventing his idea okay very good and
now what happens a lot of times when
people are attacking is you know you
leave all these weaknesses this guy is a
little bit weaker than any pawns that
black has and black should get a decent
game if he just continues with the
following plan but let's see what what
actually happened in the game and then
we'll show some crazy computer nonsense
that you guys didn't calculate okay in
this position everything is fine if
black here plays the move e5 he's much
better but in the game he decided to go
g5 and you know after this there was a
tactic here that he missed white played
here and suddenly he's winning and it's
not really a tactics class but uh
and half of these moves are the right
moves but okay now white is just winning
all right which isn't really the point
is actually the game the point is to
figure out this exercise and in this
position
you also could consider this crazy move
and after this the complications are
really ridiculous and if you play like a
supercomputer and even the computer
couldn't figure everything out I had to
like help it out and like what what
about this lot and like it can figure it
out yeah so so the first couple moves
here I mean
all right this position it seems pretty
easy we're thinking either we're just
going to simply move the rook away if
it's our turn as white so alright let's
let's take that all I did that one you
guys can do the next one now what is
white threatening Knight to f5 yeah
using the bishop again so what do you
what are you going to do about that see
how you do you guys stop this
f 6 and again not e 5 because this is
pretty bad you can't take the night
because then I'm taking here with the
bishop ok f 6 very good and now among
all the moves the most complicated for
you guys is here and if you find the
right move here you can pause and spend
like hours and hours at home trying to
figure this out then I mean you're just
you're a genius
because it gets wild and crazy and it's
all based on tactical stuff I'll give
you guys a minute for some reason and
then I'll show you the answer but it is
worth trying to understand this is like
the final point the only reason to show
this really is to ask this this one
question now is if you were playing with
the white pieces how would you proceed
from this position yeah you'd want the
rook on the G file yeah so that's why
it's planned he's going to go to h1 he's
going to bring the rook end so that's
the plan
and when I first showed this to the
computer it's like oh there's two moves
they're both totally winning and then
you know you let it think forever and
ever and it's like I don't know maybe
they're both drawing waiting out there
winning again and it couldn't decide so
I had to play all through the lines
wasted three hours of my life for this
the most unimportant part of this
lecture but the two moves you can play
here are rook to c7 which after some
crazy complications black is slightly
better and Knight to c7 which at first
thought was the best move but then it
like it changed his mind well one of the
points of putting the knight on c7 is
you're protecting a six so after the
King moves over your Queen can safely go
to g7 unlike the other line where you
just let them take on e6 because your
computer and you don't care so in this
position you of course have the move
Bishop takes here but now again all
right he attacks the e pawn we defend it
after here it's also interesting why do
I play this move so again you need to
use a little prophylaxis in this
position I'll give you a hint this
this move loses but why what is White's
threat here
yeah route g5 then you're just going to
laugh at me because I can't take the the
pond or take it unless unless I can but
right now I can't afford that you're
gonna work my vision mm-hmm then you're
but then you're clean as excess 2h7 so
it's actually quite scary I don't think
I would I don't think I would take if I
just let's waste a move here yeah I
don't think I would take I like I'll let
you go over here and then I'll try to
take your Jeep on so I think I'd yeah
but he's trying to trick me
mm-hmm yeah so when you're putting
catalyst we know what to play and I
think I just play here
do you have a threat yet I assume
there's all sorts of crazy tactics
because the computer lines are all nuts
here but let me let me let me see if you
have a threat do you have a threat
if you play Brooke h8 then I take it
ruk h7 i take on g6 then if you check i
can go to f7 I don't know I think I
think I'm pretty well defended here so
not quite and it does have to do with
the night move then I just went to e2
and for a reason
who wants to get to h5 yeah exactly
yeah the night goes here so if you take
on d2 the night goes to h5 and you lose
so again you have to use prophylaxis and
at this point I'll I'll give it away
the move is rook da intending rook d5
and if Knight h5 we take it and black
wins we start taking stuff on the second
ring and if here all sorts of wild and
craziness but we'll stop here and say
it's about equal which is why this move
was inferior and if yeah if back in this
position here you were if you saw this
position and you you spent the time and
you're like what's the difference
between Knight to c7 and enroute to c7
and he worked it all out then you know I
wish you the best of luck at the world
championship this year because okay
what's this move all about
so again white has the same idea in mind
and obviously we play Bishop takes f4 I
think that was you know the only thing
to consider here because my computer
told me so if here then yeah g7 is also
like a big threat when are we looking at
it before rip c7 like immediately
so yeah you thought about sacking
because it's yeah mm-hmm
so returning to our main line okay so we
have this this move possible and if you
take you can play here and you're just
intending to take the Jeep on so if they
they protect it you have this move and
you know and here
and they take and you go here and they
go back and you throw this check in
before you play e5 okay and then black
wins so yeah so it's all really
complicated if instead you just play
rook g1 you ignore that my bishop is
hanging there you can play here just
allowing this move okay all right whoo
well who cares I play here and we trade
a lot of stuff and this end game is
slightly better for black everybody
happy with that conclusion so uh so as a
human I think if if white just takes
here on h6 like he did in the game black
is just better but from a practical
standpoint if you take here what are the
chances black figures that all out you
know and if he does he's slightly better
yeah so I figured that yeah just yeah so
yeah yeah that's why it's great to be
white you don't have to actually
calculate stuff black has to figure it
out so that's that's actually perfect
and what also kind of makes it work is
the the presence of this bishop so you
can imagine when your queen gets to the
h-file you always have these constant
threats but uh it still worked out for
white you won the game all right so this
is asset ops key die cough from 2007 and
it was a seventeen mover so we'll show
the whole game alright
the widow we're alright so yeah Ken West
is he's leaving the room now because
it's the one where he's out of here
house thanks Ken
okay so we get this variation so it's
not it's an interesting idea this this
idea and now the check
and after hear black played the move c4
and either whites in a lot of trouble or
he's got something more clever in mind
so we stop here and again what is what's
blacks threat if it's black to move what
are we playing here like why did we
place for so if if Queen a5 which I'll
show in the next variation it doesn't
work because of the threat you don't see
yeah and it's not Queen a5 after you
find White's move I can I can show you
why yeah what Lex initial threat is
quite simple just what he's planning
here after the whoopsy for a six
he's just trapping the bishop so yeah
what is white allowed so we know the
threat and so this is also an
interesting one too because it's kind of
like in between attack and defense it's
sort of both so we know a six is coming
so we have to come up with a rather
clever way to avoid losing our bishop
here now if you combine the strength of
Mike comer and Bill Thompson you solve
this puzzle
it takes both of them Mike had to find
the first moves and then Bill had to
find the remarkable move it was great
they were like a perfect team and the
next hint is Mike found this move
without actually seeing the follow up
which is probably true you might play
this move without actually seeing why I
think but uh we're gonna get an ETA
finding the wing the young bishop of
them just see my clock you're going
around a little bit okay I take
bishop that forum
you attacked my queen alright but I tell
people to always play Queen da so
I'm soaping okay g7 free for my queen
but I'm trying to get g7 three free
person yeah yeah my knight is quite
useful at the moment yeah it's good
night
you're doing a good job over there so
let's try to do the opposite of what the
whole point of this lecture is all right
these free nobody knows what blacks
nobody knows just likes doing okay just
just what's like the most natural move
that you would play here yeah here we go
all right eight for a four so for the
moment where we're ignoring this threat
black played a six there's nothing
better so a six trapping your Bishop or
check the King Bishop to a three
excellent and you have to block with the
night if you play here now we see one of
the ideas and tactical challenges are
for Saturday so you can pause your your
video if you want but here you have
maton five yeah now can't sees it Knight
g5 and for some reason will analyze this
move alright checkmate and you know if
the alternative is taking and now we do
check check check and then three checks
so you win
okay so you have to block with the night
okay fair enough and now here comes the
point so really I could have started in
this position but like - I'd like to
work you up to it yeah yeah
alright so very well done this should be
eight
not Bishop d6 which allows Queen d8
preventing you from playing the move it
will discuss why why can't you take the
bishop in here also
okay let's let's just look at the
position first yeah and you take on g7
this is the point and it doesn't matter
where you're your whip goes either way
I mean White's doing great this is my
next move
yeah and on the seventh rank and yeah so
either way it's okay this is quite good
for late the past h-bond is also handy
so in the game it it wasn't played let's
see at some point here I can I can show
you the move that was suggested is it
here where can I show we're going to
show the move that you requested maybe
in this line okay if here Queen a5 you
can just take and go here in your line
let's go back to the very very start and
again yes I feel just like Queen a5
let's pretend let's pretend it's your
move now if Queen a5 I still have this
and there are several lines where you
take here and I just laugh at you
I mean it's nice I really needed to use
Mike my extra move more beneficially you
know here I think you just take my broke
and I don't have to take this but you
know if I had if I had use my move a
little more beneficially interesting yet
the move move point a5 just never worked
so if we go one more time back we'll
watch the actual game here now we got
this position so we didn't take a play
Queen d8 and white played like
absolutely perfect from here so it went
here the ship was attacked so we found a
way in the bishop escapes so the bishop
went in it went the long way tried to
hang itself but it couldn't be taken
notice too that this move is a disaster
I mean we take on f6
with some threats here so that'd be just
disastrous so the game saw black
developers pieces and again a very very
nice move here by white after taking
this is very nice move again 95 the
point is if you take and my queen gets
to come in here it's over
so here castle please take on c3 and
here and now his move is just as good as
another move to here you can just take
your check and then if you just get this
Queen in here it's over but he went here
the same idea now he's going to take
care check and he's going to bring the
Queen in so here black already gave it
up there's nothing to do
the Queen's coming in and the game is
over so that was the slightly more
challenging example of the night so yeah
I mean it's really brilliant stuff it
seems like the bishop is just getting
trapped out there and then after a few
moves here Bishop e8 a very nice move
and I like that that move was found
instantly but you know a for Bishop III
that was a tough part all right so this
is Luc van Whaley versus Michal krasin
cow
yeah will it be another Bishop to the
back rank and you can't take it puzzle
it does look like that mm-hmm if you
want to see the opening - we can we can
have a look mmm and yeah so yeah so it's
this crazy lion I used to play until I
realize it's impossible to play black
here hey I tried forever to defend these
kinds of positions but it's impossible
just just don't do this at home leave it
leave it to the pros and even here it
didn't work out it's really hard to play
these it white sacrifices upon but he
gets a huge initiative rate at the
beginning so I recommend this this by
opening is white and in this position
well white got all these pieces out
black took a couple pawns and we reached
this position so again here we pause one
more time we want to see what white is
threatening and when you see this
position I think when you're white
you're getting really excited there's
all sorts of crazy stuff you might
consider but when you're playing this is
black it's a lot harder to consider
those things but if you think about well
if I was white what kind of like what I
sacrifice everything I got I got these
awesome rooks my bishops are going
crisscross there's all sorts of
potential here so first think of it it's
it's your opponent's turn what uh what
does he he's threatening in this
position
so it's black to move but what is white
threatening let's let's give your
opponent to turn what would he play here
yeah rook to d7 check and we'll see this
in the game so in the game I guess we'll
go over the game first so we get a sort
of an idea of what's going on in the
game Bishop e6 was played which did
nothing to stop this threat and after
taking what happened here is very very
funny too
I like the ending I also like to show
games that are really funny okay so
white repeated very good and then he
played the best move and then he
repeated and then he played the best
move all right
and then he repeated and then he played
the best movies at fine I'll go check me
you and in this position black gave it
up
natives made his coming
and I love that he repeated like so many
times those great and they never made it
to move 40 so maybe he's just getting a
little bit of extra time there might
have been an inker Mandor maybe he was
just toying with them who knows
so I mean you're you're threatening
there's a there's a lethal attack I mean
white is threatening to meet you in this
position
rook d7 in inmate follows with or
without repeating several times
well we know the threat now so it's
black to move how do we parry the threat
rope to d7 or at least make it so that
when work to dese Evan
as it is as it was in this position here
and that's what prophylactic thinking is
all about so you know what they're going
to do and when it happens you want to be
ready so that it's not as big of a
threat as it currently is because right
now it's terminal well you play one move
and and you might survive
and it's not a turning the tables thing
it's not like black suddenly is winning
it's black is trying to draw here I mean
white white is very very active
okay Knight c5 which is definitely one
that needs to be considered that
controls d7
sometimes I go to b3 okay that's a very
good move to consider but after hear
what it did you have them think what
light would do here yeah rook f6 and
yeah this is this is bad news
okay all right and okay I'm glad you
weren't tempted to to take this because
now it's it's quite different that's
what you wanted yeah but yeah
unfortunately it just doesn't work
due to this sacrifice looking for the
black let's go forward King to g7 the
right move alright can west
yeah now our rook d7 doesn't have as
much power we can go to h6 and that's
that's all there is now in this position
I don't know where Danny is because
we're the only ones in the world that
have studied this position for hours and
hours and know why Bishop e6 is so much
better than Bishop to f5 because that's
what we spent all night doing we studied
this position by it so no we were just
trying to figure out why this is
slightly more accurate than Bishop to f5
and now even if you do you do mix it up
a little bit you can go here and this
position should actually be equal so
yeah just running away from the attack
actually was the right answer here
putting the King on g7 makes it so the
threat wasn't as strong as it was in the
initial position so excellent a
fantastic use of prophylactic thinking
to come up with the right answer there
and okay if you like these these puzzles
just please make sure to hit like share
subscribe there's all these buttons
under the video you just hit them all
index everybody for coming out here
tonight